[Music]
now obviously we should fianchetto our
bishop and then play d6
um
now the main decisions there are two
main decisions that you have to make
as a king's indian slash grunfeld player
if you're a grunfeld player you can play
d5 here i've never been a huge fan of
that move
because white gets this massive clamp on
the e5 square if you're a king's indian
player it's a complete no-brainer you
play d6 but then you have to make a
second decision
after you castle and that second
decision is whether you orient yourself
toward e5
or c5 both of these pawn breaks
represent entirely viable systems
uh but you want to be consistent if you
want to prepare e5 then you want to
prepare e5 if you want to play c5
then it's a very good idea to then
fianchetto the light square bishop now
bishop d3 as some of you may know is an
inaccuracy
could somebody explain to me why it's an
inaccuracy and on the basis of that
could somebody tell me which of these
two pawn break problem breaks we should
orient for here
so yeah so this puts the bishop and the
knight on a forkable position at some
point e5 comes with tempo but that's not
the main problem i mean that's part of
the london the problem is gonna be like
e4 is gonna become possible at some
point uh if he's not careful and white's
probably gonna have to lose a tempo
because
uh allowing this fork would be
disastrous so clearly we should prepare
e5
how should we prepare e5 first we should
make the flexible developing move we
should just play knight c6
uh generally in the king's indian the
knight goes to d7 but in this specific
instance
the knight is fine here
and now believe it or not we can play e5
immediately but
uh but just for the for the sake of
simplicity
um let's play rookie a
and let's see if he falls into it
now he probably is aware given his speed
of play that that this is a threat
and he plays bishop c2 so
he does play prophylactically here but
still white's setup is very toothless we
get e5 and in a very good version and
white's position is just not
particularly impressive so we take back
with the pawn
obviously and we've got ourselves a very
nice position out of the opening
okay so this is of course equal it's
toothless but white is not worse
so we should just play this slowly or
play this normally
alright so how should we continue
in such positions i always like to ask
the bishop a question the move h6
generally has no drawbacks just play h6
see what he does
and of course if white takes on f6
then that gives us the two bishops
so bishop h4
and
so yeah of course we have the
possibility now going g5 and we should
seriously evaluate it the problem with
g5 is clearly that it creates weaknesses
on the king's side so the question we
have to follow up with is you know is
the pin
annoying enough to warrant
the move g5 and i think the answer is no
i think that we can sort of ignore the
pin for the time being
it's true that he has the potential for
knight e4 but other than 94 there's no
other way to put pressure on the knight
and the knight has two defenders so
the knight is safe here
um
one thing that i would would want to do
here first of all we should complete our
development
our bishop is as yet undeveloped where
should we put it where would be a good
spot for the bishop
uh not f5 because the trade would
[ __ ] black's pawn structure bishop g4
would be pretty much an empty pin
on account of h3 we've gone over this
uh before and we're just gonna have to
drop the bishop back so bishop e6 i
think is the safest
and most harmonious kirk we need to okay
so we're going to play queen e7
uh copying his move and preparing rookie
to d8
knight to e4
all right so
as predicted he tries to put pressure on
the knight
and once again we should keep an eye on
the fact that g5 is is always possible
in these situations but we still don't
need to do anything we do not need to
panic
because this knight is perfectly well
protected by the queen and the bishop
so we can continue
uh as planned which means essentially a
move like rotated e8 bringing the rook
into the game
yeah this is this is a boring position
but you got to know how to play these i
mean if you want to be
[Music]
if you want to progress past this level
you've got to know how to outplay people
from boring positions that's just a
prerequisite
all right so something interesting has
happened now that he's castled
once he castles i essentially know that
he's not going to be attacking me on the
king's side
why not because well at least it's going
to be much much harder so
what move is now a little bit more
palatable than it was before now that
he's castled short
uh the move g5 now seems a lot less uh
risky to me than it did before he
castled because yes it weakens the
diagonal it creates the same weaknesses
but
uh but it's it's just doesn't come
associated with the same amount of risk
he's
probably not going to sacrifice
presumably maybe he will i don't know he
might sacrifice he's definitely thinking
about it
but assuming that he doesn't um
yeah so he plays bishop g3 our king is
perfectly safe given that he himself has
also castled king's side
all right
now um there are several typical ideas
some of you may be considering knight
takes c4 bishop takes e4 and then f5
but if you calculate concretely white
can take the knight on c6 in that
position
which is a major flaw in that idea
i do however like the
general concept of trying to push the f
pawn
the issue with it is that if you take on
e4 he takes back with the bishop and
then makes contact with the knight which
allows which forces us to lose the tempo
so we can essentially do something where
we circumvent his knight but and then
prepare the move f5 with tempo now
almost everybody's thinking about knight
h5 i don't love that move
the reason i don't love it is because
that knight on h5 is going to start uh
is going to get a little bit loose and
one of the things that he can do and
i'll explain this more after the game
because we don't have much time
is he can drop the knight from f3 for
example to d2
and that knight on h5 is going to be
very vulnerable and the trade on g3 is
beneficial to white because what's going
to happen is white white is going to
take back with the knight and look at
that f5 square if the knight gets to g3
white's going to control that very
important outpost square and it's going
to make it harder for us to play f5 so
what we want to do is we want to go
knight to d5
put the knight on a very protected
square so that he can't really bother it
and then we are ready to play f5 in
addition if you play c4 then that opens
up the b4 square for the knight that's a
common
uh type of idea right we shouldn't worry
about him attacking the knight
i hope that makes sense okay so he
allows f5 we can play it immediately and
i think he's just blundered a piece i
think that white has neglected uh the
threat against the bishop on g3 as many
of you indicated we're just threatening
to push the pawn all the way to f4
trapping the bishop on g3
yeah
and that's a common blunder uh because
okay so bishop takes c5 and that makes
situate the situation worse so as i've
advised many times uh the moment you
uh believe that your opponent blunders
you need to keep your eyes peeled
because what often happens is that one
blunder follows another you know your
opponent blunders he gets tilted
and and they try to you know to remedy
the situation but in doing so blunder
further
so rather than just blindly taking on e5
uh if you look carefully at the position
we have the possibility of taking on e4
and why is this good
because well if he takes back then we
will win a second piece by taking on e5
and if after f takes c4 he takes the
bishop this is the crux of the line we
don't have to recapture on g7 we first
take the knight on f3
attacking the queen that's the important
bit
he has to respond to that and then we
take on g7 and we will be two pieces up
that's an overwhelming advantage and the
win is going to be very simple
i wouldn't dismiss
you know this guy i think that rook 81
was the blunder and
it makes white look bad but
he played very well up to that point
but very well up to that point okay so
it takes
okay we can play king takes g7 or queen
takes g7 it doesn't really matter
um
queen takes yeah let's play queen takes
just so we protect uh some of these some
of these squares around our king
some of these squares around okay okay
so here we have one little problem left
to solve
the knight on d5 is under attack
if we move the knight we potentially
expose the rooks to a little bit of
tension i don't necessarily want to
allow that who can find a counter-attack
against one of his pieces that then
allows us to bolster this knight with c6
yeah we can very nice we can drop the
knight to e5 centralize it and then play
c6 to support this other knight uh so
that he doesn't uh orchestrate any
shenanigans down the d file
yeah that's exactly right we've got to
play a little bit faster we've got two
and a half minutes but the position is
completely winning for black
completely winning for black
okay he takes which is a blunder
thank you for the queen
and that is about his gambit
yeah okay i think i think he just got
really tilted
i think that was the that was the issue
okay
cool
um
that was a little bit anticlimactic but
it's fine
so bishop d3 as i explained is not a
move in the spirit of the london
in general in the london system you play
i think you start with h3
and
the setup that i was going to show you
guys provided that he played the correct
line
is knight f to d7
knight f to d7 you drop this other
knight back to d7 this looks like a
terrible move
um guys and part of the new commands is
you know
if i end up playing one more great if i
don't i don't but um let's just enjoy
the analysis there's plenty to learn
from here and i'll probably end after
this after the analysis for today
um so knight after d7
now what's the idea you're blocking the
bishop that may seem like a pretty
significant drawback to that move
but what you're doing is you're opening
up the other bishop and you are
accelerating the pace with which e5 can
be played
so bishop e2 you're already prepared to
play e5 you've got one two three
defenders
and one two three attackers which means
e5 is possible
well no you have to know it um i learned
it you have to know it it's it's i think
called the armenian variation
and the point is that after bishop h2
now you develop the other knight to c6
and after the move c3 which is very
typical for london players they
generally respond like that
there is another benefit of dropping the
knight away from f6 so the first one was
that you could accelerate the pace of
playing e5
does anybody know what the second
benefit is of dropping the knight to d7
yeah so now
you can play f5
and that is a very desirable move in the
king's indian and if you've watched some
of my games with min
we often we used to go into this line a
lot when i played the king's indian
against him
black drives this interesting little
pawn wedge down white's position
and then the knight returns back to f6
opening up the diagonal for the bishop
and you get this very important type of
position this uh i think this is
actually the theoretical continuation
and clearly with the center close black
is going to attack on the king side and
white is going to attack on the queen
side so white pushes the pawns here b5
c4 etc
and black pushes pawns on the king's
side
for king's indian players i think
uh this is a very good lie particularly
because in the london white often tries
to get the situation out of or get the
position out of something super tactical
uh so so this is definitely something
you should investigate if you're looking
up for something
uh relatively reputable against the
london
uh no white should break with f3 i think
that
uh min has has done that in the past
trying to break with f3 and
reopen the center
black can keep the center closed by
playing d5
black can also
take on f3 and then this e3 pawn becomes
a little bit backward and weak
so here you can pile up on that pawn
with rookie eight
yeah so f5 of course technically weakens
the diagonal but that's not something
i've talked about this before this is
one of the most innocuous diagonals that
you can weaken because other than a
check on b3 which is totally innocuous
after king h8
uh it's not that a check on c4 b3 gives
white any inherent advantage right
so you always have the h8 square for the
king this is not a serious weakness of
the king side
um
in addition
i see that some of you were worried
about d5 that's nothing to worry about
the knight can drop back to e7
the king's indian uh this move is rarely
worrisome after something like c4 f5 you
get a similar type of position to what
we just discussed
where can you learn more about this um
well if you have chess base you can
definitely analyze with an engine but
uh you can sort of search these moves
maybe an opening explorer
also you can use
an engine and just analyze right you can
you can use the leachate engine for
example
and just create a little file create a
little study
where you consider and leeches also has
game reference so you can click a button
and it basically shows you what the most
popular moves are and you can create for
yourself a little bit of a little little
file
using the engine using the top games and
just to study the theory
it's not entirely unintuitive
um
and
you know leeches is a very
good integrated sort of study feature
where you can create your own files and
stuff
okay
so bishop d3
is inaccurate c3 rook e8
and again after castles
he does not technically i think it's
called the armenian variation but i'm
not sure this is like the london this is
the king's indian london system
and then knight fd7 i think is like the
armenian variation but i don't remember
so after e5 does white actually lose a
piece here
uh had he not dropped the bishop back to
c2 does white
in reality lose a piece
no white does not lose a piece because
white has bishop to g5 that's an
important
that's an important detail
and if black stubbornly plays e4 then
obviously
after knight takes c4 due to the pin
uh you're unable to reclaim the knight
but
black still emerges
with an advantage because you can now
play h6
and now white must take the knight on f6
giving black the two bishops in a very
nice position because if bishop h4 then
clearly you played g5
and then e4 wins the piece so
in this position white has to take you
take for example with the queen
then black has a very clear plan you
want to drop the queen back
or if you had taken with the bishop
which is also possible you can drop the
bishop back it's basically the same
thing
and then go f5 and
g5 and e4 and you've got the two bishops
in a nice position so
uh so that's part of the reason bishop
d3 is a little bit of a of an awkward
move okay so he played bishop c2 which i
like that allows white to preserve the
bishop and bishop g5 is good as well
h6 bishop h4
um
what if knight g5 to save the bishop
well i mean yeah knight g5 would
technically be
[Music]
the best move
i mean at least white would get two
pawns for the piece but this is
insufficient compensation here white has
insufficient compensation for sure
maybe you can unpin yourself by playing
queen to d7 try to get the queen to g4
i think white can play this this is
interesting but
the computer likes the move d5 here just
claiming the center and then then
playing queen to d6 unpinning yourself
like that
um
okay
yeah so that's that's the point yeah d5
queen d6
all right so so in the game he plays
bishop c2 e5
trade bishop g5
okay so h6
bishop h4 and
yeah so so g5 was interesting here
before he canceled even here
but i had second thoughts after bishop
g3 i wanted to delay this move until he
castled
as we as we had been discussing during
the game so that's why bishop b6
was the move that i chose
queen e2
queen e7 knight e4
rook 88 and only after castles do we
play g5
now i think that
bishop g3
is a very serious mistake
because it allows us to play knight d5
and it's very very difficult for white
to stop
the uh
the mad you know rush of these pawns
down the king's side so what would i
have done with white i would have taken
on f6 first
bishop takes f6 and only now dropped the
bishop to g3
now what's the difference what if black
just drops the bishop to g7 and prepares
f5 here does white have a way to stop f5
and this is what constitutes i think the
key difference between this line and
what he played
here white has an additional move white
has the crucial move e4
and i think white is okay
i would have played h5 and tried to get
an attack going on the king's side
but you know white plays h4 and
and the position is very very
double-edged
but um
but the way that
that white played after bishop g3 um
knight t5 creates a very interesting
situation and i've talked about this
before
people often assume that a piece that is
that is in the center particularly at
night is going to be good that is not
true just because the piece is in the
center of the board does not mean that
it's well placed the knight is very
poorly placed here
because it's very susceptible to this
move f5
and um
in order to
salvage the game white
should have gotten the knight back to d2
does knight take c4 oh yeah so i was
going to show you why this doesn't win a
piece so so many of you proposed to this
but if you look at this position very
carefully you'll notice that white can
now take the knight
and to add insult to injury now the pawn
on e5 is hanging
and f4 is no longer possible so here you
have to be very concrete
why not well bishop c4 doesn't work
because that square is protected by
by white's queen
after 94 bishop before could we go
knight a5 threatening
this and this
that's a great idea but why can perry
both threats at the same time who can
find the way how
white can
stop or thwart both threats at the same
time stopping f5 while also taking the
sting out of bishop c4 queen to c2 is
correct
no not bishop d3 bishop d3
doesn't really stop f5 because now black
threatens both e4 and f4
queen c2 is a very classy move
creating a battery and a clamp on this
f5 square bishop c4 is no longer
dangerous because the rook can just move
away
so these kinds of moves you know they
they start occurring frequently at this
level and you've got to spot them uh if
you want to calculate well
so knight takes you five is not a
blunder no i think knight g5 is
interesting
and i think after h bishop g5 it is
entire it is totally not trivial
uh that white doesn't have enough
compensation in fact i think it's
crucial for black to find
uh the move bishop d5 otherwise white
threatens to play queen to f3
and then the pressure on the f6 knight
is going to become uh is going to become
absolutely deadly uh in fact the knight
is going to become indefensible
so bishop d5 is required
now who can tell me what what white's
best move is
white has to preferably do something
with this knight right black wants to
trade the knight the question for you
guys is should i take the knight or
should i do something else there's a
very strong and it's actually a
positional move there's a very strong
positional move here
it's it's not f3 because then i still
take the knight
it is a night move that's the hint i'll
give it's it's a night move
where should this knight go where should
the knight aim
yeah knight g3 and the knight f5
and that's a classy
maneuver then i can also route to h5 if
necessary and so i think perhaps
practically speaking
maybe the computer says black is better
but i think this would have been a very
very good choice for white
but london players don't always like
these kinds of ideas and
and so i i kind of banked on that when i
played g5
for what it's worth the the machine says
that the position is a tiny bit better
for black
after queen e6 but
nothing major no it's saying it's about
equal
um so remember that even if after you've
sacrificed a piece you can absolutely
search for positional ideas not
everything you do has to be
something insane and some sort of crazy
tactical idea
you can absolutely you know maneuver
your pieces around even after you've
sacrificed something
and at this level particularly that
becomes important because
you can't only have one mode when you
attack and the mode being like let's
bring the pieces in and crash through
sometimes you have to attack with a high
degree of finesse particularly when you
don't have too many pieces in the attack
you got to make the most of them so
bishop g3 is the crucial mistake and of
course rook 81 results in the blunder of
a piece
to make matters worse this loses a
second piece but even if he would have
dropped the knight back
after f4 the game is over because uh
bishop on g3 is trapped he takes f4
now don't play g takes f4 because that
opens up the h4 square
but after he takes f4 the bishop is
trapped
okay and once bishop b5 happened
okay he blunted all of his pieces but
basically the game is already over
all right guys um i think it's a good
spot to call it a day it's pretty late
i've had a long day
thank you guys uh take care everybody
and i'll see you guys tomorrow bye for
now thank you all thank you for hanging
out um and thank you for all the support
i'll see you guys later have a great
night morning wherever you are take care
bye
[Music]